I'm gonna pull up the story from the New
York Post Bud Light suffers staggering
17 sales plunge amid Dylan Mulvaney
controversy the latest sales data from
Nielsen IQ and bump Williams Consulting
show that Bud Light sales fell 17 of
dollars while volume dropped a whopping
21 percent
wow wow wow yo this has got some
feathers uh ruffled up that's huge
YouTube started taking down videos and
this is what I said my opinion on the
matter opinion is that the the sales
decline was bad and Anheuser-Busch got
angry and went to YouTube and said why
are we advertising on your platform if
it is loaded with people ragging on us
and so they they I think Bud Light was
like take these videos down YouTube took
down what they could they didn't issue
any strikes on channels why that would
cost them even more money I think well I
think we're gonna see that in the next
report it's going to be comparable
in terms of sale the sales Decline and
then it will it will uh the sales
decline will reduce so let me explain
in the first week when sales declined it
was like I think eight percent or
something so if they've got a hundred
let's just do the hypothetical number
100 units of beer sold this week
drops by eight percent now it's 92. next
week it goes from 92 to let's just say I
don't know 81. and they report the drop
now is 10 but it's still around the same
amount of beers a little bit more what's
going to happen is if they declined by
21 beers this past week
when the same number of beers decline
it's a it's going to be a actually I
think I got the math wrong my point is
it's going to look like the decline is
is easing off because the boycott will
reach a point that it's enough of the
market share has been removed if 20 of
people no longer buy beer then Bud
light's market cap will drop by 20 and
stay there and once it stabilizes 20
lower it they will say the the boy cuts
over the decline in sales has ended
despite the fact what really happened is
no one is coming back to buy their beer
yeah right right and you know what I
will say too I actually am Pride uh
proud of the right wing for you know
staking it Sennheiser Bush and actually
sending this message because typically
in the past I feel like we get angry
about things but we're internet Warriors
and that's about it so I mean seeing the
pushback on this uh has been great and
uh I think it has sent a message to a
lot of other corporations as well and
they're going to start being more
careful about uh what they're
advertising yeah so I actually did a
cartoon about this this a while ago
called what the media thinks right
Wingers are versus what they actually
are and the joke we were basically
making with it you know can go feel free
to check that out Freedom Tunes but the
point we're making with the video is
they paint conservatives out to be this
highly motivated Terror threat when
conservatives can't even get people to
boycott things yeah it's like yes I'm
going to give my life in a fiery Blaze
that can Act of Terror and then it's
like hey how about we like don't eat the
cupcake brand that just issued a
commercial which was just two dudes
making out it's like but I like the
cupcakes and then we see with this
fortunately my expectations being
subverted and conservatives actually
doing something yeah part of it I mean I
wonder if part of it is that so many
people who identify as you know as uh
their former marketing person said like
as the fratty humored kind of Regular
Guy felt not only isolated from this but
then attacked right you're saying I am
wrong for not supporting this I think
that is uh isolating its base in a way
that doesn't make any sense I think it's
harder for conservatives to find a
unifying product to boycott right like
maybe I don't buy the cupcakes already
like this was something that people who
probably felt specifically attacked were
like I'm done but I think that they felt
attacked I think that this is like the
sports issue where men are like we don't
give a damn about this to be quite
honest stop trying to common with the
lgbtq nonsense I'm just trying to watch
the NFL I'm just trying to drink a beer
why is this buying NFL tickets like they
still go yeah because they like sports
right yeah check us out uh so for anyone
who's claiming it's not true Bud light's
competitors are going up while Bud Light
Lost 6.7 of market share last week Coors
and Miller Lite are up 18 according to
the newsletter a week earlier Coors
Light market share was up 10.6 over the
same period Miller Light was up 11.5 I
just I'd love to see it
um shout out to Jesse Kelly because we
mentioned this every time we bring the
story up he said it's the first time his
neighbors ask him about politics the
Dylan Mulvaney thing I think there might
be something to it where you've got
dudes who feel uncool to buy Bud Light
at this point and so let's break this
down in terms of marketing terms let's
pull out our politics the sponsorship of
Dylan Mulvaney created the perception
that the beer was for young effeminate
men so already you've got this Trope
where if you're drinking Bud Light
you're not manly I mean I I don't know
about you guys but back in Chicago if
you went to a bar with your friends in
order to Bud Light they would laugh yeah
I was gonna say I felt like that
perception was already there but I guess
they'd punch you in the back of the head
because you ordered they would be like
Bud Light was for when you're just
trying to get drunk at a party nobody
cared but if you were actually going to
have a beer to hang out at the game
they'd be like you bought Bud Light like
dude get Modelo at least I mean it's an
another bush people get like a real beer
get out get a Heineken or get Stella or
something but Bud Light so now you've
got dudes who are going to show up to
the party and they'll be like I don't
want to it's gonna be embarrassing
they've basically made it embarrassing
for men to drink beer with this
marketing campaign I think it's funny
too because the boys always love banding
together over stuff that they deem gay
not saying you know I just I think that
this is crazy it's 40 year old men who
don't want to look gay yeah in the
literal sense they they don't want to be
viewed as weak or effeminine yeah I
don't drink Bud Light or anything well
they don't want to subtly signal they're
like affiliated with this in any way
right and now if you offered someone who
came to your home like if you have a
co-worker inviting over you don't know
them well you're like can I have give
you a Bud Light like this is no one
wants to be here
they've created this is the meme Bud
Light created with sponsoring Dylan
mulvania guys like you are already
seeing the left Champion Bud Light and
the right say Bud light's bad so what's
going to happen is you are going to have
people at Pride parades cracking Bud
Light and it's it's a it's a Whirlpool
for for Anheuser-Busch There Is No
Escape for what you have done to your
brand the left Will Champion Bud Light
it will be the the markings of great gay
pride parades of Pride nights and
conservatives and regular people are
going to be like I don't I don't want to
do all that so they went from being a
generic alcohol get drunk beer to a
leftist activist political brand that
people aren't going to want to associate
with I will say I don't drink beer
really but I hit a point where I was
like I have to know how to order like I
have to have a brand name to say when
somebody says do you want a beer and I
pretty much always uh order yinglings
because I know they donated to Donald
Trump yeah and I was like but no here we
go I'm not enough of an acquired taste
to be able to scrutinize it I don't know
if it's good or bad beer it's fine and
it does it immediately like I don't I
know that I am supporting a cause that
I'm at least pretty much okay with right
like I wouldn't buy these beers because
now it's affiliated with a whole
conversation I don't want to be a part
of yeah if I if I'm getting like a cheap
light beer then Yingling's my go-to for
that exact reason but is England really
light it's not really that light well to
me it is why were you like holding
English or like Guinness well well
hold on you said Guinness I do have I'll
have an IPA sometimes but Guinness is
good though I think I just want to see
I'm not a beer guy I just want this
summer to be like the summer of the
small Brewery like everyone's like I
can't buy Bud Light okay I'm going to
get that like one that's on the corner
like my friends buddy bottles it I
ordered I think I ordered while we were
live 600 cans of conservative dad's
Ultra Rite Beer nice nice that's what
it's called
no no it's Seth weathers he put a put a
video on on Twitter where he smashed a
Bud Light with a baseball bat and said
and said stay the F away from our kids
we should have just been like this beers
full of testosterone
I remember yeah I don't know who again
it was a stupid marketing campaign
because remember it's also not like like
because Bud Light went from a kind of
meaningless name uh you know I just want
something cheap into like this is no one
was like yeah that's my brand of beer
it's like I remember way that's why
their sales are dropping there's no
loyalty Bud Light exactly well you
exactly if exactly
um
I'm sorry to cut you off but I feel like
a woman interrupted I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm using my privilege to speak over you
I feel like in hockey culture Bud Light
is a big thing but also take a peek at
in what who is pushing Back Against The
Pride nights right now it's hockey
players yeah specifically so Bud Light
is big in hockey but I think he's also
the most outspoken against the lgbtq and
a lot of places like the hockey room is
just like a sports arena they just put
down the ice you know that's how it is
in Dallas uh I think that is what I'm
finding most interesting because when
they're saying the volume like what
people are ordering going down it means
that uh certain restaurants or like
venues or whatever no they are not going
to be able to sell this stuff so they're
not even going to order it yeah and
that's pretty crazy but it makes sense
because why would you waste your money
on it well and so I guess my point was
just that I used to see it like okay you
have the very very low tier where you're
dealing with like Rolling Rock and
Keystone and then slightly above that is
sort of where Bud Light is but not Bud
light's just below all of it for me I'm
never ever drinking it again I mean
look I wouldn't drink Bud Light I
understand like I'm not gonna drink
Coors Light or Miller Lite or Miller or
Budweiser I've just always viewed them
as like generic garbage beers who do you
think you are I'm already seeing the
videos on Instagram too because I don't
have Tick Tock but I'll see like the
tick tocks that get posted on Instagram
of men like doing Blind beer taste tests
and they drink all of them and they
guess them and then they get to Bud
Light they talk in this like really a
feminine yeah that's hilarious they're
getting like millions of likes wow yeah
it's really funny they've destroyed
their brand they really did people are
making fun of it all the time and it's
all these men like uh they drink a Bud
Light and they're they immediately and
it's just it's hilarious dude and and so
look the question is is anyone going to
want to sponsor Dylan Mulvaney after
this this is the algorithmic mistake
these are Dylan Mulvaney's popularity is
completely rooted in a robot randomly
choosing dull Mulvaney videos to show
the big Brands then saying this gets
views sponsor it and now their brand is
ruined I think they will because there's
a lot of Brands like Nike which
conservatives were so mad at Donald
Mulvaney for having this you know I
thought we were mad about Colin
Kaepernick yeah because we tried to
boycott them once upon a time
about uh you know Nike enslaving
children and then using the child labor
for to make you know their products but
Dylan Mulvaney is why we're mad at Nike
it's like conservatives have the memory
of a goldfish I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna lie to you guys but anyways the
companies that are already all in on Dei
and are already woke and know that
they're
I I guess their customer base is going
to be more behind them because they're
supporting a Dylan Mulvaney type who's
been demonized by the evil right wing I
could see that I think instead of small
Brands no yeah no of course not small
well small Brands wait no big brand is
going to do it no I think it's literally
sorry I think it's literally all gonna
be what you said which is these these
brands that have carved themselves out
in the market as a progressive option
they're gonna go can you believe how
people treat it that poor Dylan that
sweet Angelic soul and they'll put him
all over their branding and then they'll
be the the yeah
people are saying to boycott Maybelline
and Nike and all that stuff and it
doesn't work the same way yeah because
women want to look like Dylan Mulvaney
no no no
oh my God
if I was wrong women would be boycotting
all these products but they're not no so
so hold on hold on so I'm gonna make
sure I tell all of these feminists who
are defending Nike and Budweiser I'm
gonna tell them well you know what I you
do look a lot like Dylan Mulvaney so you
know it must be look and if they're
insulted by that that is on that's my
point they're a transphobe I think part
of my point is this they're not offended
they have a man you see the ad campaign
of the guy wearing bra a bra and panties
no that was horrible it's it's a man
wearing a bra and it's a company's like
they announced they're gonna make bras
for males and then all these women are
like they're like men don't need bras
though like men don't need bras like
they don't have boobs but they're doing
it anyway women
overwhelmingly are more in favor of
these political views in these things
yeah because we're more emotional
absolutely yeah
so it may be that that conservative
women don't want to look like Dylan
Mulvaney and it may be that privately
these liberal men don't want to look
like Dylan Mulvaney but they clearly
really do resonate and support Dylan so
I think it's a compliment to tell them
they do look like Dylan Mulvaney thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time